all right I don't want to spend a ton of
time on this just because she she's such
a despicable person and obviously a liar
that it's like how much time do I need
to spend reminding you that
congresswoman Lauren bobert is a liar
but this is actually sort of an
important story there was this debt
ceiling vote of course and Lauren bobert
is now claiming that the fact that she
didn't vote one way or the other on the
bill was a sort of protest because they
weren't letting her do her job and it's
this big moral stand that she's taking
except now video has been released of
Lauren bobert trying to Sprint into the
capital to vote she was just late she
just missed the vote that's all that
happened so let me give you the comings
and goings of this here's Lauren bobert
back in Colorado
explaining that she is protesting
against the debt ceiling Bill she's
against adding debt she tweeted quote
call it a protest there's no there's
absolutely no way to ever justify adding
another four to six billion dollars in
debt this is more DC self-created
garbage that I will always fight against
and here's the video that she put out
about this hey everyone I am back in
Colorado but let's talk about DC no
excuses I was ticked off they wouldn't
let me do my job so I didn't take the
vote once again Washington's power
machine shoved a multi-trillion dollar
bill down our throats refused to allow
debate or amendments disregarded
everything we fought for in January to
actually allow representatives to do
their jobs and instead they served us up
a crap sandwich call it a no-show
protest but I certainly let every one of
my colleagues and the country know I was
against this garbage of a bill yeah it's
a no-show protest
except here's video
taken by CNN associate producer Morgan
rimmer of bobert trying to sprint in and
realizing being told the vote's over you
missed it does this look like someone
who's not trying to vote
there is Lauren bobert
sprinting up the steps of the capital
to try to vote
this is a lie she is a liar it's
political theater but it is very low end
political theater Lauren bobert has
nothing interesting to add about the
debt ceiling she has no relevant
insights she has no particular
experience that makes her someone to
listen to on this issue she isn't even
important enough for anyone to bother
paying attention to whether she is or
isn't voting and she's turned all of it
into a big story about herself but it
was all a lie she just was late to vote
and then retroactively came up with this
stupid story
the only other thing I'll say is she won
by only 500 votes she can be defeated
she has an opponent Adam Frisch and it
would be great to defeat her in 2024